the small intestine is about five meters
long and about one inch in diameter
based on these measurements you would
expect the surface area of the small
intestine to be about six square feet
but it's actually around 2700 square
feet or about the size of a tennis court
in this video we will discuss the human
digestive system watch to the end for
some more amazing facts like this I want
to start this video by asking a simple
question if you remove more than half of
your liver what is the time taken to
regenerate it completely is it a one
week B 1 month C 6 months or D 1 year
write your answers in the comments below
let's see who gets it right at the end
of the video so the human digestive
system essentially consists of two parts
the digestive tract and organs of
digestion without the organs the
digestive tract is just a tube and
probably the same stuff will come out
that you will put in without the action
of the enzymes from these organs the
digestive organs release several
chemicals that turn this 30 feet long
tube into a powerful digesting factory
that converts complex food materials
into simple easy to absorb small
molecules that are then utilized by the
body for various purposes
the human digestive system starts with
the mouth the mouth consists of several
structures that perform the first step
of digestion the teeth tongue palate
help to chew the food which divides the
food into several hundred pieces this
serves two important purposes it makes
swallowing of the food much easier and
it increases the surface area of the
food making the action of enzymes much
faster the mouth also receives the
cretians from salivary glands the
parotid gland the submandibular gland
the sublingual gland and also many -
lavery glands
the saliva contains two important
enzymes in the Emil ace and the lipase
which helped to start the digestion of
starch by breaking it into smaller
sugars and fats into simple lipids the
tongue also contains thousands of taste
receptors contained in structures known
as taste buds these give the information
about the four basic tastes so after the
food has been chewed and mixed with the
saliva it then passes into the pharynx
and then into the esophagus through a
series of controlled muscle contractions
known as a deglutition reflex the
pharynx is a conducting zone that is a
part of both of the respiratory tract as
well as the digestive system the pharynx
continues down as esophagus but it also
receives the opening of larynx
anteriorly
the epiglottis is a piece of cartilage
that covers the opening of larynx when
we are breathing the epiglottis is open
like it is in this situation the
esophagus is collapsed and the air
passes forward into the larynx when we
eat the larynx opening is closed and
this prevents the food from entering
into the respiratory tract and it is
passed down into the esophagus instead
the next part of the digestive system is
the east of Vegas which is a 25
centimeter long muscular tube through
which the food passes into the stomach
it passes through the posterior
mediastinum and enters the abdomen
through a hole in the diaphragm and
joins the stomach the whole length of
the esophagus contains smooth muscles
which propel the food forward through
muscular contractions known as
peristalsis these muscles are very
strong at the lower end to form the
lower esophageal sphincter which has a
valve like function
it remains constricted at all times to
prevent the contents of stomach from
entering into the esophagus except when
we eat and drink to allow one-way
movement of food when this muscle loses
its tone it leads to many diseases like
the gastroesophageal reflux disease
the next organ in the digestive tract is
the stomach stomach is a Jay
shaped organ and it is connected to the
ESO Vegas at the upper end and the
duodenum at the lower end it has a vital
role in digestion it has large volume so
you can eat large amounts of food at one
time which is digested slowly by
controlling its release through the
stomach although it's true you can live
without your stomach but the patients in
which the stomach has been removed have
to eat very small quantities of food
frequently the stomach has layers of
smooth muscles in its walls which turn
the stomach into a literal mixer the
layers of the stomach wall are mucosa
submucosa muscular layer and the
outermost coating the serosa
the smooth muscles caused waves of
muscular contractions known as
peristalsis which cause mechanical
churning of the food the stomach
releases powerful strong chemicals like
the hydrochloric acid sodium chloride
and powerful enzymes like pepsinogen
which digests proteins
since these chemicals can damage the
stomach wall mucus which is secreted by
the gastric glands forms a protective
layer on the inner wall of the stomach
the wall also secretes bicarbonate ions
and has tight cell junctions to prevent
damage from HCL all these factors
prevent the damage to the wall and allow
maintenance of a low pH which is
required for the action of pepsin which
is the active enzyme the lower part of
the stomach is called pylorus and it
also has a strong smooth muscle
sphincter which opens usually after one
hour of taking a meal till then the food
has been converted into a semi-liquid
form known as time which is slowly
released forward next the food passes
into the small intestine which is a 5
meter long tube divided into 3 parts
duodenum jejunum and ileum the small
intestine has the main job of digestion
and absorption of food this is performed
by abundant enzymes through the liver
pancreas gallbladder and a small
intestinal wall itself the first part
the duodenum is the shortest which is
about 25 centimetres in length since it
is connected to stomach at the upper end
it
receive strong acidic chyme which can
potentially damage its wall so it
produces bicarbonate rich alkaline
secretions that neutralize the acid so
you can see in this diagram the duodenum
receives secretions from gall bladder
pancreas and liver these secretions
contain numerous enzymes that digest the
food and convert it into simple
molecules that are easy to absorb and
utilize by the body
the liver which is a vital organ of
digestive system produces bile which
consists of water
97% bile salts bile pigments and mucus
these secretions are delivered to the
duodenum via the common bile duct the
gall bladder is used to store bile and
concentrated since we eat a lot of fat
in our diet which is not water-soluble
and cannot be absorbed as such bile
helps to emulsify the fats in the chyme
and leads to the formation of micelles
which are easy to digest and absorb the
pancreas which lies behind the stomach
has both an exocrine as well as an
endocrine part the endocrine portion
produces insulin and glucagon click on
the card above to learn more about the
endocrine system the exocrine part
however secretes important digestive
enzymes like the chymotrypsinogen and
trypsinogen also amylase and lipase
chymotrypsinogen is converted into
chymotrypsin and trypsinogen is
converted into trypsin which are the
active form of these enzymes and these
enzymes digest proteins amylase digests
carbohydrates
whereas lipase digests fats
now approximately 1r after you take a
meal the food starts to enter the
duodenum where all these enzymes and
bile start their action the food then
passes slowly from duodenum to jejunum
and then to ilium most of the digestion
of food takes place in the small
intestine the wall of the small
intestine contains layers of smooth
muscles which cause segmental
contractions that move the food forward
slowly the carbohydrates fats and
proteins and other nutrients are
completely digested slowly over a period
of many ARS now if we talk about
proteins these proteins are converted
into peptides and simple amino acids by
the action of many enzymes from the
stomach and small intestine the main
enzyme which act on proteins are the
chymotrypsin and trypsin which are
pancreatic enzymes the fat in our diet
is converted into simple molecules like
fatty acids and glycerol from the
enzymes from pancreas and liver the
pancreatic enzyme lipase is the main fat
digesting enzyme whereas the bile from
the liver helps to digest the fats the
main enzymes that digest carbohydrates
are amylase from the pancreas which
convert complex carbohydrates into
simple ones and also enzymes from the
small intestinal wall which are known as
brush border enzymes these enzymes
include extra neighs glucoamylase
maltese sucrase and lactase so all of
these complex food is broken down into
simple molecules which are easy to
absorb now if you look at the
microscopic structure of the wall or
small intestine you can see that it
consists of small projections on the
surface which are known as villi these
villi in turn have more smaller
projections on their surface which are
known as micro villi the presence of
villi and microvilli on the surface of
small indesign increases the surface
area of the small indesign tremendously
which makes it super effective to absorb
these digested simple food materials
these molecules cross the cells of these
micro villi and are then taken up into
the bloodstream and lymphatics in the
vessels present in the center of these
villi
so after most of the
digested and absorbed in the small
intestine the rest of the food passes
into the large intestine the large and
Stein begins with the cecum which marks
a distinction between the small and the
large colon the large intestine is
divided into ascending transverse and
descending colon the descending colon
then leads into the sigmoid colon which
then leads into the rectum and that
finally leads into the annal canal
overall the length of large in Stein is
about 1.5 meters which is about
one-fifth the length of whole GI tract
the large intestine absorbs water and
any remaining and probable nutrients
from the food before sending the
indigestible matter to the rectum the
large intestine contains over 700
species of bacteria that perform various
important functions in digestion and can
you believe the bacteria in our large
gut is about 200 grams in weight in the
large intestine the microbes act on the
remaining food and produce important
compounds like propionate butyrate etc
these compounds are used by the large
intestine cells for their nourishment
important vitamins like vitamin K are
also produced after this the remaining
material turns almost solid which is
compacted in stools and stored in the
rectum till it's excreted through the
anus so this was a brief review of the
human digestive system now coming back
to the question we asked in the
beginning that was if you remove more
than half of your liver how much time
will it take to regenerate it completely
and the answer to this question is four
to six months yes in about six months
you will have a brand new liver
guys thank you so much for watching this
video if you want to see more videos
like this subscribe to our YouTube
channel and for all the flash cards and
upcoming notifications follow us on
Facebook in the link in the description
below if you want to connect to me
personally you can follow me on
instagram at lost in the north's if you
are interested in travel and landscape
photography as well